citizens of the
reject Nation it is a momentous occasion
first time one-on-one remote collab
between me John and Michael over at omn
media to check out Thomas the Cru in
Mission Impossible 7 dead reckoning part
one IMAX 3D how are you feeling about
this man are you excited I'm ready I'm
ready for this thing I
missplanit this would be out soon no
it's perfect in fact it works that's a
good segue everybody go subscribe to omn
Media first and foremost I was actually
using your reactions to kind of get back
into the mindset for this and catch up
on some of the details and I'm excited
to see what kind of uh deconstructive
and also riffing magic we might be able
to create today we'll see what happens
but before we hop into the movie your
mission should you choose to accept it
is to leave a like on this video also uh
if you want to help support the channel
and grab a little bit of Swag in the
process go ahead and check out the
reject Nation shop.com store new and
improved got tons of lovely designs up
there we got the new snip snip and a
soda Star Wars inspired designs we got
the who influences The influencers
Watchmen inspired design it's all uh
part of the inhouse reject ecosystem and
if you want to be up to dat and Cutting
Edge go on over there and last but not
least if you want to get the full
experence alongside Michael and I you
can come on over to patreon.com theal
reject sync up with your own copy we
can't show you the full movie but you
will be able to enjoy every moment that
doesn't make these reaction highlights
and check out omnimedia on patreon as
well Michael's got tons of watch alongs
over there included so hey without
further Ado are you ready to to roll you
ready to to do some impossible missions
I'm impossible to do
yes
perfect let's do this thing
[Music]
we're going to the trench he's going to
fight the
Meg he's going to fight Aquaman maybe
that is the crossover we need hey you
know Tom Cruz said flash was the movie
we need right now and
so it only stands to reason Aquaman's
neck
operation poova day 74 the active
learning defense system we are testing
continues to operate flawlessly good we
are navigating under the arctic ice cap
by dead reckoning and 5 days from home
he said it is it a
place I I guess or a a state of
being we are at this moment the state of
the Art of War only now before nah it's
all been leading to this the mostar
didn't know what he was talking about
ever devised by man and we are
impossible to find a challenge but we
got a team just for
you we have a submerged contact
designated seon 83 exhibiting tels of a
Us Virginia class submarine steady
course 1 0 come up easy on a standard
belt as an American and a Navy person I
understand all of this I wrote
it maybe later you can tutor me on the
metric system firing solution is
tracking at a distance of 15,000 M oh
firing solution just to a step change to
10,000 M nothing moves that fast whoa is
there turning with us again he can see
us it's a cat and mouse game weapon
round Diagnostics on Sonar and Fire
Control something is Sir he's flooding
his torpedo tubes freaking Skynet yeah
it's like if Skynet was also Hunt for
Red OCT oober left full all ahead fly my
brother is left full answering all ahead
fly cavity launch counter measures
launching counter
measures whoa fire top two fting
two it's fun to get some like submarine
Thriller Vibes back in these enemy
torpedo still homing range 800 M right
right stand by this is tense dude yeah
this is the captain hands bra for impact
enemy torpedo impact five four oh what
impact
brace um it's it's gone it vanished like
it was never there son where is the
enemy vessel and where are my brown
pants a torpedo is running through
impact with enemy submarine in three oh
one
wo enemy submarine has vanished he's
gone sir it's kind of spooky he was
never there Phantom it was right there
the instruments don't like there's the
theme yeah shut down our torpedo hi
Captain shutting down
torpedo what an odd day for this crew oh
oh oh
no ghosts in the machine to go home
Captain arono is not responding it's
coming right at
us oh my god
oh ra 200
[Music]
meyow Collision
oh
jeez oh my God damn that looked painful
hey at least they don't have to drown
[Music]
yeah damn
stop torpedoing yourself put some
different music on we'd have a bond
opening yeah
right oh wow the key food
delivery it's not the fun side of
Amsterdam
clearly this is where they take all the
foreigners yeah right before hostile
happens do it it's like Michael Myers
India Zulu
254 Bravo echo1 One Call Sign
Maverick what is the earth We Live and
Die in the shadows for those we hold
close and for those we never meet
bars hey welcome to the IMF oh you made
the right
choice so the impossible choice he's so
going to blow up
yeah you've been marked son I'm sorry 30
years ago you were offered the choice
join the IMF or spend your life in
prison Oo we will never forget just as
you will never forget the death that
brought you to us all those years ago
[Music]
yep the stakes of this Mission are
higher than ever your habitual Rogue
Behavior will not be tolerated should
you choose to accept it is imperative
that you listen oh he's good at that
your government is searching for a key
its vital importance to us is none of
your concern Rude the involvement of
your friend ilsa fou yes she killed a
courier in Istanbul and we believe he
was carrying one half of the key we're
searching for that was slick your
government has put a price on her head
and these bounty hunters are out to
collect it even they headed for the
Arabian desert's empty quarter in search
of your friend find the bounty hunters
go on to the desert and acquire the key
and deliver it to us this message will
self-destruct in 5 seconds classic and
now he's just got to you know go out
into the desert and then walk until he
can't walk anymore and then he'll talk
to the guy from The High
table he's going to have to sacrifice
his finger well and in this universe he
can still get back to Michelle Monahan
so you
know that he can so maybe Ethan Hunt
Wick has a shot Tom Wick Tom
Wick look how they always just reset the
standing of everybody half the time they
do one of these continuations like we
were on good standing at the end of the
last one I felt like they saved the day
we were all good and now they're like we
hate you Ethan go kill your friend you
and your methods that have worked every
time will not be tolerated this
time damn the ey padge too
[Music]
getting uh not another sandstorm let's
go I'm getting dark Universe flashbacks
right
now hey I've I've never even bothered to
watch it oh you're depriving yourself my
[Music]
friend where's Nick Miller where's Jake
Johnson
emot yeah
hey I would take an Ethan Hunt mummy
side
quest oh
oh nice cover
damn is it just me or there more Dutch
angles in this movie there's quite a
few oh gosh damn so the eye patch like
lets you kind of give all your focus
over to the to the scope
eye
this is an interesting little set piece
yeah I just can't not think of Call of
Duty though right now
yeahoo this entity has reunited and it
feels so good behaving like a computer
virus then a tapeworm is that Mark
Gattis distorting any and all digital
information with which it comes in
contact dude this dude in Tom Cruz must
be hey can be trusted as fact at the
outset it concentrated primarily on news
and social media which was of little
concern to us as purp yeah dude when the
entity breached Saudi Arabia
intelligence director what are we doing
just all this one room
man Carri
ow it's it's Pierre despero he's back oh
The Entity has since become sentient oh
no it's it's is Skynet it is oh my yeah
it tricked them into shooting themselves
the full force of its energy is now
directed at a single objective the
world's intelligence networks of course
the entire intelligence Community is
racing to Archive hard copies of our F
before our most secure data centers are
breached and corrupted they're also
buying all the Blu-rays
[Laughter]
stock up on your physical media yeah
before Disney deletes it and humans are
the weakest link in any security chain
one that has been patiently listening
reading watching like this guy personal
secrets for years able to beguile
blackmail bribe or be anyone at wants
hasn't created a Terminator already has
it no she's got some decadent
alliterations though you don't want to
kill it sir you want to control it of
course why do we do that Mr krid hey oh
wow welcome back I knew I recognized
that voice on acquiring two halves of a
cruciform key and what does it unlock
not exactly sure your doom somehow has
the power to deactivate freaking box
they hope to control it harness it no
buyer is passing somewhere through the
Middle East sometime in the next 72
hours we believe that he already has one
half of this key of course the other
genuine half of the key was in the hands
of this woman where is she now she's uh
dead
okay I sent a man to find her oh does he
have it krid well at present I don't
know that sir he's refused to come in
he's taking a sick
day
mrf when there's a mission none of you
can handle you just leave leave word for
nameless man and hope he gets the job
done
yep should he choose to accept
[Music]
it Presley created to ensure there would
be no uned oh oh no they're authorized
oh that's a look that's chilling
[Music]
whoa there's like a is it is it Tom is
it Tom oh is he mased get Mas did he
just choose like a a random creepy dude
to be masked up
[Music]
as yes what a reveal dude yes I love
these like early on switcheroos although
Ethan Hunt definitely has a flare for
the dramatic he could have choosed a way
more nondescript looking guy yeah I put
the bounty on Elsa's head and I didn't
ask her to steal the key she did that
for reasons of her own you get her out
of trouble and she always found her way
back in she's a lot like
you oh yeah
nice wait it's me it's
me
nice she is one of my favorite parts of
this franchise she grew on me real quick
man
burn the dummy you're dead you stay dead
Ean
way we are all dead remind me of
Christian Bale in
Salvation wherever the other half of
this is whatever the completed key
unlocks I will find no one should be
trusted with control of the entity
agreed stay out of my way I can't do
that let's go you've tried this before
buddy yeah you know how this goes come
on mission of yours is going to cost you
dearly oh that's some foreshadowing in
that frame her face in the background if
I don't get that we're going to have
company real
soon smart to introduce him in a scene
with a bunch of other recognizable
people and then this Tom Cruz Switcheroo
like really kind of builds up his
presence yeah I thought the guy was
going to be a plant for like the AI or
whatever this thing is and to whom am I
speaking CIA director Eugene kitridge
your agitate
was found unconscious in his home 10
minutes ago security has him entering
this facility 15 minutes ago
wow you guys are a little delayed a
security team is on their way if you're
in any danger simply hang up the phone
before I count to five one oh so just
how do you plan on getting out of here
now that the stakes are
set oh my God how do see like you
just going to Tran okay snake equipped
tranquilizer yeah dude wow man how did
he not he he knows this guy come
on you were dealing with him since the
beginning and no doubt his later
exploits have gotten back to you the
first
movie yeah you were literally just like
defending his Antics to these
people oh Kirby's back isai Morales
oh that's right P
damn I'm I'm damn can't keep up I know
this is like super kinetic I love these
movies have expanded now that like you
know the cold open is like a full half
[Laughter]
hour anything in this man's possession
is of vital importance it must be
captured intact the man himself is
Expendable great shot yeah right come on
deception sabotage and sight Warfare PR
a purposes ladies and gentlemen a mind
reading shape shifting incarnation of
chaos that is the most perfect way I've
ever heard this character described
absolutely and delivered with that
perfect Shea wigam oomph putting us on
an unsanctioned Mission which has gone
Rogue before it even started meaning
this very conversation in Act of treason
or as we like to call it Monday sure an
easy
Tuesday any day ending day you're going
to sell the buyer our half of the key
while we figure out the buyer's
connecting flight and book us seat on
that
plane so you can follow the key wherever
it goes which you hope is into the hands
of someone who knows what it unlocks
well it's kind of a par for the course
give over everything we need to activate
the thing to find thing this guy oh my
God not personal but it is personal you
know who I'm surprised has to come back
Jeremy rener I liked him in this yeah
right like I feel so bummed he exit it
cuz he had such a great you know rapport
with the rest of the team I know there
was like the whole like is he going to
take over but like they tried that with
Bourne already that didn't
work yeah I'm like Jeremy rener I like
him he's not Tom Cruz or Matt Damon
really Ethan would you care to explain
to our friend the net Ranger now I am
just as capable of writing code as he is
no
comment there going to be a bunch of him
right way to kill the entity while I
just hold his soldering iron probably
definitely oh having a tech off tell me
where he is nah it's going to take their
combined strengths to take down the
[Music]
entity do that power was that strut
yeah so
hope he ends up with a broken nose by
the end of this yeah just fit every time
I see
him oh my God I mean I get it but that's
great facial comes back with
a Tom Cruz deep
fakes oh wow did you do that no one is
safe from fineas
Freak yo this this is great I want his
mixtape I got him where is he e gave
five in a kind of racist outfit no well
that's going to be on them they're the
ones that's going to pull him over I see
the buyer get him the buyer is auto Von
bour he's connecting to Venice departing
in 30 minutes on flight 10:31 Halloween
[Music]
flight don't get too close to the guy
who was supposed to be you oh wait
[Music]
did yeah oh wow the way they positioned
her in that frame yeah I thought I I
couldn't quite pick up what was off
about it yeah like that the color of her
jacket and the way they had her like
just flit through the frame this is this
is good there was a suspicious bag alert
it was on its way to flight 1031 to
Venice it's the buyer's plane it's
Ethan's plane what if somebody is trying
to smuggle a bomb onto that plane oh
should we P it no guys guys you hear me
find that bag I'll direct you go tell me
is there something wrong uh nothing to
worry
about whoever she is she's no spy she's
a saief she's with
[Music]
Shield
nice yes I mean oh I get it you thought
I was someone else I'm not
interested give me a chance
I'll
scream yeah you will please
do the start of a beautiful relationship
this key whoa you pick from that Man's
Pocket it's worthless
oh in the world he's done every stunt
imaginable now the man learns magic the
man you stole this from to complete a
transaction lead this airport with both
of these without ever knowing his pocket
was picked and before he boards his
flight in 7 minutes
minutes let's see what kind of put
pocket you are put pocket you're a thief
you want the money and I can give it to
you so what's the play I sure hope you
know what you're doing your mission
should you choose to make me force you
to accept it keep it something remember
me
by the alloy in that key she took off
the buyer doesn't match it's counterfeit
I expect nothing
less talk to me Luther where am I going
Benji head down the stairs in front of
you I forgot what he was doing I know
got so pulled into that
moment I'd be afraid to unzip it yeah
might have like a trip
wire the buyer's in the waiting area
above you top of the escalator all the
units are headed in your direction your
location is going to be crawling with
agents anytime now
perfect oh yep whatever it is I've just
activated it hello Benji I want to play
a
[Laughter]
game also it appears to be nuclear how
big big enough to matter to everybody in
this airport I suspect can you just well
I haven't got any tools then find some
is you just going to start opening bags
yes please oh my God who who just gets
to play with a bag of tools I know like
what airport is going to allow you to do
that come on come on come on come
on I got
it a cyinder there's uh eight wheels we
need Tom
Hanks yeah Mission Impossible D Vinci
Code the the wheels they spell out a
message you are done penji done they not
d o n e d u n n it's my last name yeah
oh yeah Benji done boy it knows who I am
ooh
oh that's creepy and these like low
register piano keys like there's some
spooky in this movie for sure I speak
without a mouth I fly through the air
without wings a drone an echo that's it
that's it that's it that's it not bad oh
no that's only one Are You Afraid Of
Death it's a psychometric test the more
questions you answer the more it'll know
about it oh stop giving it information
about yourself I lied it know just tell
it the truth say are you afraid of death
yes who isn't
damn oo nice be careful what's in her
Palms see what you did there would you
happen to know what's always approaching
but never arrives what is always
approaching but never arrives she knows
tomorrow yes good who or what is the
most important thing to you say it I if
I there's no other choice say it he says
I don't
know
buddy you're always the heart of these
things
BJ whoa oh dang I've got no more
questions and there's one more wheel how
am I supposed to give answers since I've
got no questions that must be your final
test I've got 45 seconds oh my God my
god
dude you leave him alone I know harm one
hair on Benji's head there's one more
riddle I'm working on it 15 seconds e it
easy what's the real the time it takes
me to explain we're all going to be dead
come on Ben why do we always end up in
these
situations oh
[Music]
god oh nice nice
W good
luck are you kidding me it was nothing
in it it's empty what do you mean empty
there's nothing inside this little oh
you got Batman she took the key damn
haly Atwell I got it she's heading for
terminal
E but you got compan e uhoh whoa oh oh
oh no oh AR dude damn oh my God excuse
me oh excuse me the run the Run sorry
come on Haley ell join in the Run we
need him running on one of those moving
floors I know this is a perfect
[Music]
opportunity
damn it's a nice little Domino like she
gets away from him he gets away from
[Music]
them
oh what else can we get Tom to run on
that he hasn't ran on before yeah let's
get him on the roof of a terminal can
we they must have been sitting around
going what's another way we shoot this
yeah like there must be it's got to be
in the contract right it has to be and
there's got to be a dream list of
scenarios and ways to capture it she was
seen with our man at the airport in Abu
Dhabi who is she where is she now agent
Peggy Carter I've seen you watching
those too uh shield and stuff and and
Asia car like like I I'll have to get to
to her show it's good it's worth
checking out it's got its own
Vibe it's my favorite resist and arrest
and R which one of this women is you
I've never seen these before in my life
they were in your purse a put pocket put
them there her lawyer is here my lawyer
oh who has the pleasure there's been a
surprisingly minimal amount of ilsa so
far part of me wonders if she's going to
return in this one or not right I mean
they could maybe just holding it off for
part two she left Abu Dhabi with a
certain key there was no key one that
you could mistake for a pendant the kind
that you'd be tempted to hang on a chain
around Amelia's neck your
wife we both know you gave it to your
mistress Valia on August 21st oh
now pull your hand out and show your
allegiance to the
[Laughter]
table
oh there's a bit of Indiana Jones in
this movie a little bit in different
ways but I keep getting those inklings
like it it's it's got that old kind of
Serial fun adventure Bop to it and this
is like when we see him at school before
he goes back out into you know some wash
buckling Adventure someone out there
hasn't the slightest clue they're
holding on to that key for you an
unwitting Courier the perfect accomplice
oh that's interesting you get me out of
here and I'll take you straight to the
key now start with who hired you contact
with the client was almost entirely
electronic email texts encrypted
naturally almost
pardon there was a a dead drop in a cafe
in Luxembourg an envelope tiet to ababi
a picture of you oh and you in
instructed to deliver it to Venice party
at the duali palace tomorrow midnight
let's get a club fight going the friends
from the airport saw them in the hallway
a few minutes ago you could have said
something sooner well they were chasing
you not
me I love the way they're just playing
against each other
[Music]
dude just carry this Joker gas
everywhere yeah know Green
puffs
wow damn no no
no huh I am a
jiggalo do the run no one can catch you
when you do the run that's why Tom Cruz
like the flash so much it's so
predicated on
running
[Applause]
ah damn oh oh God not bad looks like she
was really driving that
stunt yeah this is the most realistic
driveth through one of these like alleys
I think we've seen so far I
agree got to pull over gra pull over
listen I'm try you oh jeez holy
wow those freaking sound design edits
man like that gave me a heart attack
dude I'm like
flush
oh
yes
God damn it they got get rid of those
women it's okay oh here we go everybody
down down get down get
down oh
[Music]
oh
oh get
wed classic it's it's night and day now
[Music]
oh let's go Riot
girl I like how messy all the car action
is in this so everyone's just like
crashing into stuff ripping doors
off
ah
oh my God all these motorcycles rocket
enjoy
it oh my
God I just like how annoyed by each
other they
are oh oh
perfect oh there's a shot finding us a
new car
nice
yep let's go Fiat bumblebee well I mean
that gives you a little more I mean put
you closer together a little more wiggle
room with the other hand that's true
short of putting her head in your
lap jeez hey give it give it time I'm
sure there's some awkward reason he'll
need to have her duck for fire or
something yeah M thanks okay yeah you
ready I'm ready whoa oh gokart go
yeah the way the sound cut there was
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
whoa
woo oh my Lord
man this would be excruciating in debuck
I saw John Wick 4 and 40x with a friend
and it was just like being pummeled for
3 hours it's just like someone beating
the crap out of here I've never I can't
imagine the stairs scene yeah no it
really was just like constant like this
would be the same oh my Lord oh baby
baby oh my God and in the driver's seat
again call it
it
yeah wait
what that is awesome that pretty good oh
my
God
whoa It's the tires just try to go
straight oh damn you're driving you're
driving go go go just go straight go
straight I love how she's like every
time it cuts to PO she's just like
having the time of her life I feel like
she was just allowed to do whatever she
wanted with
[Music]
this any moment they're going to drive
past Dom Toretto and and Jason mima's
big spherical bomb yeah
dude
drive through
him come on car turn into
bumblebee
yes
damn
wow oh no perfect right into the opening
of spiral from the book of
Saw
whoa oh wait how what when did that oh
the paper clip damn it after all
that okay well at least she gave it to
him this a little bit like a jigsaw
trap there probably going to be a train
coming yeah oh my god let's get that
subway car I hope they cut to him with a
yeah with just the severed steering
wheel
o yeah
yes handcuffed to a steering wheel that
thing didn't pop off the track yeah
maybe that car is like light enough and
small enough
that
hey all right glad we didn't have to
wait till the next movie the event is
being hosted by none other than our
favorite International arms trafficker
and black marketeer
Al this is defeat from your AR
sunglasses I've been running facial
recognition on everyone in the
airport
uh wait oh a ghost
[Music]
who the only person in the airport with
no identity oh that's how he was able to
like flicker
away it's protecting him you saw him
didn't you
papa someone I thought died a long time
ago a loose end does he have a name he
calls himself Gabriel of course he has
no recorded past he's a Dark Messiah The
entity's Chosen messenger wolf how do
you know this I still have a few friends
left in my6 yay did these friends of
yours happen to say what the key unlocks
leads somehow to the entity's source
code Jake jillen Hall your friends in my
six had they contact you did you speak
with them face to face they couldn't
risk meeting me in person so oh no all
communication did you open a fishing
email digital we can't be sure that was
the entity they said they just needed
some details for my Amazon
package you have to go you are you have
to go Ethan what if it wants us to leave
like you made us leave the airport and
what if it wants you alone at that
party any move we make it's probably
considered it anything we do we have to
assume that it's counting on us to do it
if he want want to beat this thing you
have to start thinking like it you got
to start acting un sensical it's my
first time in Menace it's mine too it's
a
date a you too yeah if anybody could
maybe make it
work o that's that's gorgeous also
really
eerie
okay all right now we're in Bond theme
song
yeah it's the it's the Scott Atkins
fight where the water walls I a
drink I'm waiting for someone so am I
let's wait together we can wait together
if you say so and your
grace oh wow jeez that makeup that my M
get up suppose while we're waiting I
tell you a little story oh you're
obviously not the person I came here to
meet It's Your Story Grace uh-oh who is
this he looks like eight different
people all at once is that uh isai
Morales is that his name yeah I keep
like he just reminds me of like Billy
Zayn mixed with like eight other actors
that are just all coming to mind sure
sure we'll figure it we we'll get each
one of them by the end Timothy olon
that's the one I was thinking of like if
you put him and Billy Zayn together what
happened to Marie same thing that
happens to all the women he uses as well
as anyone else who touches that key and
right now the only thing standing in his
way is you nothing anyone says is true
just remember that and he promises to
protect
you it's been a long time Ethan you
should have killed me when you had the
chance if it isn't John
L it's good to see you
L welcome back back from the James Bond
Universe such a gentleman
too yes ma'am I believe you have
something for me you hired me why H
picked you I put pocketed
you
oh nice she doesn't have it where is it
it's in the last place you would ever
think to look
the first place Ethan Hunt always looks
I connect a buyer and a seller sometimes
for money sometimes for information but
I don't know why I was like why does he
got Sonic screwdrivers in his pocket you
know it's some point he's going to have
to reverse the polarity and there's only
one way Gabriel represents another
interested party this party was arranged
by that interested party whoa whoa
conflict of interest is that interested
party
[Music]
waa oh oh damn oh no this machine knows
how to
party it only knows techno yeah it's
only got EDM what makes you so sure you
will get the completed key you have one
half of it why don't you just keep the
key and all that power for yourself
because she doesn't know what it unlocks
she's so much fun to watch I know what
it unlock lox I'm not here for any key
as I'll have both halves in hand
tomorrow and with only a few changes to
the present the future is all but assur
it's going to put Ethan Hunt out of a
job tomorrow on the Orient Express it
knows that you've already chosen your
Suitor that you intend to mate the two
halves of the key in a desperate grasp
for control another crossover
potentiality completed key will lay
itself at my feet provided someone dies
tonight evil dies tonight T night her or
her a oh he oh God Ethan's choice he's
afraid it's
afraid ooh help me complete the key and
I will kill this thing help him and
you'll die too help him everyone dies
wow I'm sorry BL a that look though I
have to be on that train tomorrow and I
have to have that key and I do not care
how I get
it little twit little
[Music]
emphasis
oh oh
nice oh
everyone learned magic for
this
wo oh damn that kick you hear me I need
eyes R is leaving you to call on foot
she has the key we here go need to find
her where is
she
wow
jeez all the stuff shot in like
Silhouettes and the moving
[Music]
lights and of course no Global Espionage
action movie is complete without a
billion
candles run
Tom that narrow and turn left the entity
is knocking out satell lights faster
than I can hack into damn you guys need
expressvpn I don't see her where is she
down the narrow alley and turn left okay
copy that oh no Ethan our comms have
been breached you're talking to the
entity turn left oh my God the brid to
your left what's scary is this is going
on right now I
know yeah literally just AI generated
his voice quick left or right it doesn't
matter she's on her way to the minich
bridge where Gabriel is
waiting oh
wow yes ma'am
o
spooky now that is a
presentation
o
oh damn love how close quarters this is
CL
phobic
a
[Music]
yeah
oo o
m these stuns hit
hard oh jeez dude ow yes at least your
range of motion is pretty restricted
here yeah gives you a few options oh
tickle her Tickler her tickle her
yes wa nice with the kick ow cool
fight
ah I could if I wanted to and I
don't I was hoping it for
you let's
[Music]
go
o ah
[Music]
oh oh WN God the trade back and forth
like the counters to some of those
[Music]
moves oh
no
[Music]
no I know anything can happen but
they're selling me on this right now I
mean knowing this like how everything
goes I would you'd always have to like
double triple check everything cuz like
like check her neckline yeah we've seen
people like fake dead and they just had
a mask on them before you know maybe
she's able to concentrate and like move
her heart slightly to the right she was
born with it on the other side
yeah it's got to be something I'm the
reason she's dead no she's the reason
reason your Al
o if there's anything I can do to help
the White Widow is expected to be on the
orian express where buyer is waiting to
take receipt of the complete in verified
key but she doesn't have the complete
key that wiow
doesn't oh no your future boils down to
three options now prison death or the
choice your mission oh to come with us
come with me now I wanted to hear them
say it I know I
know W uh I don't know why that one just
like yeah I like it it's the wrong kind
of
uncanny I still think three has the best
mask
[Music]
transition ooh I'll tell you these
movies at least make me be like God I
need to see more of the world yeah right
it's a great like ad for travel wow nice
that was great I always love how these
masks also change your bone structure I
know and everything about you your teeth
your accent wa wait wait stop whoa oh
okay nice okay I'll help you find the
key and your friends wipe my slate clean
you'll be dead if I stay I'll be
safe you'll protect me wa is that it
uhoh yes no oh I can't promise you that
it's the test but I swear your life will
always matter more to me than my own
that moment was Tom Cruz talking to the
audience and I modified all calms to use
skywave radio not as reliable as
satellite but completely analog immune
to The Entity cool but as your friend as
your life objective Kill The Entity what
about killing Gabriel he knows there to
key unlocks will you still remember
that everyone else thinks they can
control the entity only you want to kill
it and it's afraid
nice get the key get off the train alive
do not kill Gabriel do not alter the
plan I I oh I got a bad feeling right
now it's dead what do you mean it's dead
I mean it's fried I managed to make a
widow Master with Grace Just shed out in
the middle of making yours no just get
the key and wait I'll come for
you she yeets herself out the window
yeah promise me you'll be on that train
I will be there you can't keep me from
them I will be on the train whether I
will be in the train is a different
thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
entirely
oh oh ooh damn at least it wasn't
perfect got to keep it
grounded nice
Cut W oh okay
no sneaky well the way he came up I
thought he was like inflating yeah I
know I thought they had like a
doll nice little camera tilt with the
[Music]
Mallet God slowing down of course not
wouldn't be an impossible mission if it
slowed down what would you do with that
key if you had it I hand it over to my
superiors because that's too much power
for one man to have no one man should
have all that power or for anybody to
have and maybe that's what Hunter is
thinking uh let's get him on the team I
like this guy now that we've actually
got like an actual scene with
him I mean sh's always great but but you
know self Drive activated oh
no oh this will be good how's the entity
not controlling his car or laptop yeah
it's got to happen any second you like
drugged or something
oh oh my Lord that tripped me out oh
this is the
[Music]
switch well now she's drugged yeah CU
know she said she had to be on this
train or she died or whatever so I was
like she they preemptively forced her
hand either that or she was just like
super
nervous
Alana changed and you never will
interesting smooth you know that was
just very very subtly Haley Atwell like
the way she came out of there carrying
herself really really well done I feel
like that's part of the fun that doesn't
always come through
necessarily you son of a bitchard
no you're not atanta
mopis no the atanta I remember was yhy
drinking hot chocolate in the twillery
garden with her mother you
I thought they were about to confront
some of these issues with the mask thing
it's just my terms have changed my
agreement with your late mother it's an
agreement that kept her from dying in
prison
sure this one you know her she's not
exactly hard to miss well if you got got
to know her you see she have a few good
qualities well I did a she did a job for
me and you to protect her from everyone
and no one can know that I'm protecting
her
careful
[Music]
careful crab
oh good
yes oh you at two kosas you must be the
one they call Paris
oh yeah I was going to say these guys
have to get it I said the key would be
on this train and exchanges happening as
we speak you don't know where the lock
is not exactly and this is where you
tell me a
story this is where you give me some
Exposition we were able to transmit an
early copy of the AI to Russia's newest
submarine a beta test the ai's objective
lay in the submarine Sonos sphere the
heart of its defense system the AI went
rogue and it went rogue it's Ethan Hunt
AI it's his brother it's his secret
computer
brother and only by using the entity's
original source code can it ever be
controlled or destroyed God both know
the secret to controlling The Entity is
buried deep in the sebastopol's memory
oh no since neither of us want anyone
else to find it I figure why not form an
alliance of course
you're the only person on Earth who
knows where the sasto is the only
one
whoa you will betray us and you'll tell
Ethan Hunt everything you've learned
because he spared your
life
who whoa whoa wait a
[Music]
minute oh oh damn
no this with the little lights it it's
got a pair this key has got to change
the
world looks like both like a an ornate
religious you know token but it also
looks kind of like a little gold
[Music]
submarine
oh
no that's it that's it oh no how
can this be it you can see the train
right I see the train what about it and
you have a
parachute if I can make it across the
valley and intercept and land safely on
a moving train do you copy yes I
copy okay I need you to take a step back
and pull yourself together because I I'm
under a lot of pressure right now yes be
assort of
Benji I got to get away from this
mountain look over your left
[Music]
shoulder
yes do the death jump evil coneval if
only had a squirrel suit he next
[Music]
one D
damn my
God free
Fallen that's sound cut
jeez
wow
o hey progress hey all right accept it
oh accidentally hit declined we just got
to do it again well I started
[Music]
over damn I'll sleep better just knowing
that's in the right
hand it's a pleasure to see you again
what don't let him out of your
sight oh nabbed
it yep what I miss I see the train I
don't think I'm going to make
[Music]
it ke can she sense him
kill
her oh yeah what do we
got
oh perfect timing but but I will accept
that some AI in that parachute Genera AI
Genera AI a a a a a are you
okay a
no oh
no that's a hurts but it's a good moment
where is the key it was just
here what
no of course it had to be you I'm going
after him okay you you stopped the train
okay what how do I do that you'll figure
it out look it up on
YouTube grab you got your
phone gosh where does this movie cut off
I have no like is it going to have I I
don't know what the end point is yeah or
if they're going to if it's just going
to Trail off or
something back on top of a train where
it all started
o oh damn
o oh he checked what are you doing here
unless you want to be sorting dead
letters at the postal service tomorrow
you'll do exactly what I tell you your
Sidekick was right man it's time to wake
up Shay
Wiggum and his like little like puff up
there kind of look oh wa it's like the
first
one
[Music]
oh my god wow oh God oh my
Lord
freedom I know but she locks Ethan I'm
the only one who knows ug remember the
mission
yeah
M
yeah I love the looks in his eyes just
like what are you doing man it I said Dr
I like that these two have been in like
an a whole other movie pretty much
trying to keep up with this
movie just take
him cover him cover great he's the one
you want I don't care about him h i want
you
no damn the antiz put that truck there I
guess or it blackmailed somebody to put
it there yeah who saved your life saved
your life bro everyone on this train is
going to die unless you do exactly as I
say oh
trust okay that that shot is against the
green
screen
oh
you that's how you going to stop the
train Miss
youbody true American know how boy it's
my fault if anything happen hey I got it
we got it Go Team
nice
the lighter of course what's going on
since you're not really here sir it
shouldn't concern you yeah that wink
hell yeah you get him
buddy yeah
teamwork
nice W
yeah I've got you
but who's got
you whoa
yeah
yep
a
Spiderman
ah
oh
no if only Tom Cruz had been like
strapped to the front of it like it's
Spider-Man
too
oh oh
[Laughter]
come on we should be good we should
be good we should be good there's plenty
of train to hold two
cars oh one car brakes what are you
doing come on
the literal worst car to be in right now
oh my
God I love they did
this what
no this is a jigsaw trap oh no the floor
is going to catch fire now
yeah that was just
nuts yeah what's this car going to
do
oh
oh keep going
dude it's never stopping in a way this
is kind of like falling down all those
stairs at Sacra cor once
again train car got to stop eventually
oh not the piano you got to trust me or
not you got to trust
me wow spider Tom spider
Tom got trust me jump
please
oh that that was
almost very ugly
I swear to
[Music]
God palom pal got your pal pom for the
win palom with the
save ah oh yes
[Music]
nice Ju
submarine
[Music]
yeah it can only carry one oh no you
have the key you have to
go oh yeah right on time no
no oh that was
smooth he
sa yes yes Ethan Hunt tells me you're a
man I can trust huh really after all
that stuff with you I choose to
accept just goes to jail yeah the key is
only the beginning wherever it leads
whatever it takes to get there hold the
key to the world's end my friend the
world doesn't know it but they're
counting on you always as it should be
global warming will find the sub yes
once all the ice caps have melted
finally good luck
Ethan where is
[Music]
it w my God
man and just off screen there's the the
crashed uh submarine from a few months
ago the Titan sub just around the
corner man what a ride that was uh I
don't know I I was kind of unprepared
for how crazy that one was yeah and I
mean you know granted seen the franchise
like they they only get crazier and more
intense and more world rending and more
complex and convoluted but even still
like I'm still sitting here like with my
fist clenched and on the edge of my seat
it's dude just like the the cast I mean
I know like we had that room full of
people we didn't spend too much time
with them but like still here's this
person this person this person this
person like the entire way through this
movie I mean they they assembled a good
Ensemble like between you know the main
crew and the additions to that but also
the shadowy figures that make up you
know the higher ups of the organization
you know Carri ows in there the guy from
Top Gun krid coming back freaking Rob
Delaney in there cuz yeah like you know
i' I'd Revisited Fallout most directly
coming into this but you know you've
you've kind of shotgunned through the
series you know in the recent months
again you know like what's your first
kind of impression how does this stack
up I'm not the kind of viewer who feels
the need to like rank everything
immediately but you know as you're
sitting here how how are you feeling
about it I uh man I I think one thing
that I felt with this one especially and
some of them you kind of get this but
like maybe this the recency of it but
like I felt like once this one opened we
never really stopped like we had like
maybe one or two small little scenes
that kind of let us really not even like
catch our breath just take in another
breath before it was like you're you're
we kind of went on like a dive and we
just had to be like and then just go
right back into
it yeah they give you like a couple
seconds of levity here or there or you
know like a moment's piece before
something else just like kind of kin
into the scene like I I'm a little
like I think like if had I known like
going into this about the AI aspect of
it like this Skynet magic McGuffin thing
that's just going to end the world
because it can predict Us by reading our
actions our history and get to know us
blah blah blah that whole thing I would
have been like that's cheesy but like in
the past couple of weeks and the past
month and I'm just like we got to be
careful with this man yeah no
that's the thing it's it was so funny to
to watch both the Creator and this
because you know like they're both two
like big AI oriented things and and I
only suffice to say like the creator
doesn't actually like depict or or
really dive into like the the modern
moment themes about AI War as this is
like literally everything we are afraid
of right now like recreating voices
feeding and misinformation across you
know all of Technology uh and being able
like that whole thing about like erasing
um the Gabriel character like in real
time from all the footage and stuff like
that like I think with these movies and
it's funny like watching watching back
uh one of your reactions in fact I had
this thought of of you know because you
have to catch yourself during these
movies in moments where it'll be like
wow like that's surprisingly kind of
realistic but then you realize like well
no it's not but the way that they're
orchestrating it feels you know tangible
right this is an aspect of mission
impossible that I always enjoy but that
does at a certain point in each movie
just sort of start to liquefy my brain
in terms of all the different twists
turns alternate identities and people
posing as other people and like you know
and then this huge whatever the McGuffin
is and whatever crazy world rending
Stakes it produces but but this one
without going too wacky m without being
like fade of the Furious yeah uh you
know it managed to orchestrate an AI
threat that you know felt Salient and
didn't feel too directly specifically
Skynet or something like that even
though it's very much you know in that
wheelhouse like it's it wasn't like too
far it was mildly Fantastical in a way
that it's only feels like it's just a
couple steps from where we are so like
you know a lot of the previous ones was
like oh we're going to blow this nuke up
this nuke this nuke this nuke it was
like the last what three it was always
yeah just a big bomb basically we had to
stop or a virus which you know fair fair
on that one um but like yeah it it like
it it could have easily been super campy
or cheesy or like a little disconnected
but I I think the closer we get the more
it's just like well it's it grounded it
really nicely and we never really like
fought it it like it was more of like a
supplementary tool while as much as they
kind of talked it up as like this all
looming allseen eye that's everywhere
and while it does do that we were never
like directly fighting it which that I
think that could have probably pushed it
too far into that that area I was kind
of worried about but like we kept it
kind of grounded on Gabriel which I was
I don't know if I missed it cuz like my
like you said like this this one just
kind of like it kept you going until
like eventually you're just kind of like
you're you're just strapped
seat trying to hang on him being like
the the left hand of this entity mhm I
like the I like the idea of that but
then like it seemed to have implied that
he was also chosen because it detected
that Ethan was this thing's greatest
Nemesis on the planet yeah so it was
like statistically this is the one
person who can stand against Ethan Hunt
who's the one person who could take me
down right and it's like it it played a
psychological game from the get-go H I
don't know it was just pretty wild like
at the end of the day no matter like
what it just I don't know it just kept
it in a nice little grounded pocket that
was just fun without going too far One
Direction while still doing all the
things that were just very familiar to
the franchise and dude the I don't know
again cuz it's been a minute it's been a
month since I've seen one of these like
I don't know if we had that many running
shots in a single one of these like they
always had them
but like we had what five six something
like that different times where that was
the focus of the sequence was Tom Cruz's
run we had them like in Mass it feels
like and this is technically if this was
meant to be like one of two you know as
it's titled it just makes me wonder like
what what's the sum total going to
be yeah is like in the next one are we
going to go to that extent where it is
just like the entity Unleashed launching
everything or whatever like you I guess
you have to imagine like Luther says at
that one point cold logical unfeeling so
it'll probably be something maybe a
little less dramatic than that but it
does seem like okay now the entity is
sort of like left to its own devices and
it's going to be pushed into a corner
cuz Ethan Hunt's coming for it so I have
to imagine like there's a good amount of
Mayhem and this one certainly is whereas
like four and five and six all kind of
have these I mean at a certain point
they start putting in these connective
tissues but this is the one that seems
you know the most overtly like hey the
story of this installment is not over in
a very intentional way that's not going
to be just us reacting to the previous
film in the next film these are yeah two
chapters of a whole story um and I mean
in doing that like I thought this
managed to pretty well kind of find a
place to stop without feeling too random
about it it doesn't just kind of stop
see that's what does yeah dude that's
kind of dude when I saw the bombs on the
bridge and the train was going over I
was in that moment like he probably like
in the edit or whatever I'm like don't
you dare cuz in the moment I thought I
thought that was like I the audacity if
this is like Fade to Black here I'm
going to
scream will those Duke boys make it out
this time yeah well I mean that's what
fast X did pretty much no yeah pretty
much and uh and I it's weird because you
watch this a movie like this now and
it's an interesting time and and I know
a lot of people really enjoy this I know
Greg and Koy weren't so hot on it I know
the box office still done quite well but
not quite as well as maybe imagined or
or they had hoped and one thing I was
thinking of watching this was like oh
it's interesting to watch as you know
it's like Mission Impossible I feel like
before at a certain point in time
managed to really differentiate itself
and kind of soar above at least for a
little while you know the most obvious
Touchstone which is like a
and now watching like you can feel the
influence of Mission Impossible on many
things um that while I was watching this
now I was like okay so I can see where
maybe like a John Wick has taken the
torch and run with it or how fast and
furious or other things have been
influenced by this so there are these
moments where you almost feel like
literally down the street this other you
know big Blockbuster scenario you just
saw might be happening like not only
that like if we're talking like you know
our big Blockbusters the the summer and
kind of thing like that that that Vibe
it kind of carries along with it we we
also share the same location in those
three franchises right there on the last
entry so like doesn't Jurassic word
didn't Dominion go there too yeah like
well no I think that was Malta it just
looks the same yeah yeah similar ath all
we're all doing Da Vinci Code intrudes
now like you said like during the
reaction too it was like you just
imagine Jason M moa's Doom just kind of
crashing through as Tom Cruz is just
kind of over here and then they enter
the club and you could just like if you
like just in the background of the
camera and the shot like completely un
no attention given to it and you just
see like people just fighting and J
shots in the background it's just John
Wick in the background well no one's
paying attention all these different
movies going on all the same time I feel
like someday a mov like that will be
possible yeah no that would be that's
what the internet is for that's what you
guys is for make it happen make that
edit find an AI video generator and have
it stitch them all together uh I I liked
I liked the aspect of uh The Entity kind
of giving the movie sort of a like an
actual kind of ghostly element like I
thought they did nicely to to have it be
this technological thing but to not
treat it too not treat it in all the
obvious ways you'd expect that and like
going analog and finding ways of staying
off the grid and the omnipotence was
nicely represented but also in a way
that's restrained enough to create some
tension for the next time and I liked
having like a bit of that Gothic like
especially in some of those nighttime
sequences when you're in these Alleyways
in Italy or wherever it is you know with
these soft lamps and these Shadows
everywhere and and again just the nature
of this machine that can be everywhere
see everything you know there's
something like kind of innately sort of
Gothic spooky about that to me which is
just like a flavor I wasn't expecting
along with yeah there's some like
Indiana Jones in this some old west
Train Robbery stuff in this so I like
that there's continually sort of pulling
from the pantheon of you know set pieces
and and film stylings and and stuff like
that and I like too that that at least
the Crux of this movie Part of Me
expects the next one will be a bit more
allout but I like that this was largely
about like we got to find just the thing
that gives people access to this nobody
knows where the actual thing is and it's
like just the idea of the power uh is
large enough I know they're kind of
doing both the power is here and it's
operating but also it's like people are
trying to gain control of it that's a
Folly in and of itself and you know it's
that debate of like well should we grab
it for ourselves or should nobody have
the access to this whatsoever right um
and so you know I I appreciate that
angle of it um and you know like in
terms of these movies it's like I had a
really great time I'm curious like you
know especially having gone through them
much more recently comprehensively than
I have does it still feel like they're
firing on all cylinders and and fresh I
guess you know cuz like this certainly
invigorating it's got all the movie
Magic the stunts and the action really
hit but you know like is it uh does it
still feel fresh I guess yeah I I mean I
think it's still like all the sequences
while they you know we see similar
things they did a lot of fun Unique Kind
of plays on that from the switch to the
Fiat to the handcuffs like they they
kind of did like a Frankenstein of
things we've seen before but like in an
order that made it kind of fun and
playful and fresh with the giant tank
smashing through everything going after
and then you have this little like the
way they played with the sound as it was
going around it was like they kept it
kind of fun it does by just nature of
being a part one does have that kind of
you know open-endedness of it that you
can't avoid void in the situation but
kept the energy High the stakes fairly
High and the I think the thing that kind
of they tried to do in this that maybe
they did better in some of the previous
ones that I I kind of felt along with it
is that like Fallout it really felt
personal to Ethan in the way that it was
this Revenge plot from uh why am I
blanking on his name the the the guy
that They carried over that from that
the previous film from
oh come on blanking on his name
dang s Simon Solomon Solomon Lane
Solomon there you go Solomon Lane I I
had a a list of notes to remind me of
the last
couple yeah no I mean you eat them
that's the thing yeah like he was like
he was like the Mori arti to his
Sherlock and I really liked that and
then he to the point where he
manipulated his wife from three into the
situation to just make it as personal as
possible should he seed like there were
some of those Stakes that I felt like
they tried to do with this backstory for
Gabriel that we've your memory is
fresher we we've not seen him right
these are new flashbacks that's before
the IMF that's before he ever signed on
so all of that was new whoever he killed
I don't remember if that ever came up it
never stuck in my mind I feel like it
would have so like that seems like we're
diving into we're drudging up a part of
Ethan we've never tackled before but
they it just was like it didn't they
didn't really commit to it in this one
and it makes me wonder if they're they
will later I guess coming into that it
just kind of Felts like they I don't
know if it was a scheduling thing I
don't know what it what it was it felt
like they just all right we're we're
done with ilsa fou I know yeah I'm I'm
curious as to if she's going to stay
dead it certainly felt like she is dead
and I'm bummed about that because I
think she she is a really nice
counterpart for Ethan Hunt in particular
because she is like the MI6 version of
him um and they have a unique
opportunity to kind of have a
relationship in a similar lifestyle that
doesn't come with the whole superhero
like I can't have close people you know
I feel like in the middle chapters they
especially three and four it seems like
they were kind of figuring out who the
Ensemble ought to be um and I feel like
you know she's been such a great
addition and she clearly has all of the
elements she can do the acting clearly
she's a terrific actress but she can
throw down and really sell these stunts
and and who this character is um and I
don't know if they're making way for
just Grace to be the new her or
something like that or if there's
something behind the scenes I guess yeah
I don't know they try to instill
throughout this that he's got a pattern
yeah he thinks he's saving these people
but he's really just buying them time
you know that line I think that uh krid
said somewhere in the middle there mild
case of fridging kind of
but yeah I mean I I one of us had to say
it I guess because I I I hope that
there's maybe like more than that to it
because there are elements that yeah you
can look at this and go like oh okay you
know like we've had her she's done a
good you know run with the series and
now give Ethan Hunt some more anguish
and and let's get a new you know uh
strapping like a revolving door at this
point a little not so not as much as
Bond but like it it's uh it that's
that's a thought that crossed my mind
during the movie like when when I they
were starting to foreshadow everything
and then we were we spent like a good
chunk where we never even checked back
in on her and then we spent all that
time with Haley Atwell with Grace and I
was like hm yeah little I was like I
could smell it and I was just kind of I
was mildly just hoping it wouldn't go
that direction but I didn't know how
with the story that it was unfolding how
it wasn't going to go that way but I
still enjoyed it like it's still good
but you kind of you still kind of have
to acknowledge it like I can't I can't
in good faith like just dance around it
yeah yeah CU it's that it's that
Troublesome thing of like well you can't
kill Luther or Benji unless it's like
the last one or something I don't know
if you did I would find you yeah people
would be very upset and I'm really I am
upset that they would have killed off uh
ilsa fou um but it yeah it becomes one
of those things like well we got V on
theing right now yeah yeah exactly and I
mean certainly Rebecca Ferguson has has
plenty of other things to be doing again
I don't know if that had any to do
anything to do with her wishes or or
whatnot but yeah that that was a moment
where I was maybe taken out it it's
those two elements really is like the
the most Troublesome thing about the
movie is I liked isai Morales uh quite a
bit as Gabriel but the flashbacks aren't
really enough to fully like engage my
investment with this guy Beyond like his
main Charisma and stuff like that you
don't spend a heap ton of time with him
you know what he means to Ethan and you
know that because he killed her now
Ethan is in danger of Killing Him Etc
and so yeah it's one of those things
where her death feels more functional
than truly like for the characters and
his involvement while interesting enough
isn't as impactful it's like having krid
back is like more impactful because we
know him a bit from before and you get
him muddled up in the like okay where's
his Allegiance he's kind of in a gray
moral space right now CLE he wants
control of this power um but also is
still kind of okay with Ethan Hunt at
the end of the day um you know you've
got more attachments it's like almost
like he has like a uh understanding that
he's kind of like a storm he can't
predict it he also can't make it not
happen so he just has to live with it
and roll with it yeah it's like as long
as the storm rages well what's the worst
possible outcome well nobody gets the
device and I guess that's better than it
falling into the wrong wrong hands the
wrong wrong hands
yeah so so I guess yeah her being
dispatched for the sake of that
character irked me a little bit and two
I mean I think I liked a lot uh the
guy's name is Greg Tarzan Davis who
played dega the the the side kick the
partner of Shay wigam uh uh I like you
know Shay wiggum's a great actor he pops
up a lot in roles like this these days
uh I liked that he got to be on you know
kind of the gray like oh is he should I
come over the Ethan Hunt side or not um
and I really liked his back and forth
with uh with uh his partner but that was
another thing that I've seen kind of in
a few movies lately where it's like okay
you've got these guys who are just there
to add more complications who are just
always kind of showing up third to every
location but they also they're not on
the know of what's going on and then
once they kind of figure it out maybe
they'll make their switch which does
make me kind of Wonder like what they
what role they'll play in the second
half uh I hope they take a little more
substantial charge cuz I mean in the
couple of small scenes we got with the
with like his partner and all that I was
like man he'd be a good team member you
know we got that one that one scene was
was enough to be like yeah I would love
to see a little more of this guy or
maybe you know get some new blood on the
team and and yeah it's just like you
know they they show up for like one or
two Line scenes throughout so I was just
like okay you're bothering to have these
guys hopefully in the second half
they'll be expanded or something but
here I'm like okay so this is just a
type of character you need and needed
one of those actors in Shay Wiggum who's
just like got all that presence and
Veteran you know status that you know he
doesn't really even need to act he's
just the bringing The Presence by being
here at all do you did you get any of
the feeling that Gabriel along the way
was just doing it cuz he felt like he
had to at this point or did you think he
believes in the entity holy there was a
couple of scenes in particular that just
made me think does he is is there a part
of him that wants Ethan to be here in a
more than a getting at Ethan way and
like a
help yeah hey man I can't say anything
for obvious reason but I also have to
try cuz it's going to know otherwise
yeah and I can't like just ask for your
help but I could see it it would be
interesting certainly especially in
maybe if that goes that way in the
second part after this setup that could
be cool I hope just in some way shape or
form yeah we have more reason to like
actually be invested in the back and
forth between the two of them uh I
thought Palm Clemen if uh was a lovely
presence I I I hope that character can
come back again just because again she's
this sort of Rogue presence amidst
everything but uh just her physicality
and her presence alone like that's kind
of you know out of all the characters
one of the more slight ones certainly
but uh always leaving an impact and I
didn't really while I would certainly
have taken more I wasn't feeling as much
like in the Shea wigam instance where
it's just like oh you're just here to
show up every 20 minutes you know right
whereas like when she that fight they
have in the little Alleyway and stuff
like that but yeah I mean Carri Elis
Mark gtis uh Charles Parnell is the guy
who was in Maverick like a lot of great
character actors across this great stunt
worka yeah yeah oh that's right that's
her name yeah from from Game of Thrones
and stuff yeah yeah yeah she's great
like everybody in that room was it was
just
like yeah and I hope surprised we got
Carrie Elis as long as we did I didn't
say I I thought that would we were going
to be done with that entire room after
that scene to be honest his couple
scenes I thought he really made count
and it's like he really showed up to be
like I loved the especially that later
scene on the train car when you know
you're getting all these reveals of like
oh who's really trying to make this deal
and him being like I'm the only one who
knows you know I thought just the way he
was able to throw away and slime through
those lines with that restraint but with
all that presence was just yeah it was
so much then he gave it away and then
now he's not the only one that knows
good job I good job did you going did
you notice that like when Haley had the
Vanessa Kirby mask on they didn't change
her eyes but no one noticed I was
wondering the same thing I thought I was
going crazy for a second I was like she
had she she doesn't have brown eyes
right she like striking like
yeah I was like her brother didn't say
anything about that yeah I wonder man
like that's the thing is it seemed like
in moments during that scene they were
cheeky alluding to the P point out with
the m he like something's off and he was
like oh you just changed your outfit and
maybe he just wrode it off or didn't
think about it after that but like I
thought I started to think I was crazy
and was misremembering everything
because nobody was acknowledging it and
I was like it just
I just can't believe the script
supervisor and the and the makeup team
and everybody else along the road would
not notice something like that so I have
to imagine I don't know maybe they just
chocked it up to like the machine's
malfunctioning this is the best we can
do they tried to like steer away from
the masks for like a part there in the
middle cuz they were like we can't keep
doing this right and at least this time
he was like H well we got one we give
you a couple mass scenes but like for
the when we need it need it we we limit
we we broke you down to one at least so
I I did I did like that you know that
aspect of it especially with them yet
again working on the outskirts made me
thinking back to the beginning of this
how we just kind of reset I was like how
did we get back into bad faith again I
was like what happened in the interim is
my was like you never they never tell us
half the time like what happens between
these films but like there's times where
I'm just like what the hell just
happened I thought we were cool it
really feels like this is a what have
you done for me lately Universe where
just like between any number any one and
two installments you like everybody's
standing and like you know uh
friendliness versus antagonism can just
completely change I appreciate too that
they went back and without doing it too
obnoxiously you know they gave you some
moment we have kri kri back so we'll
give you some moments that hearken to
the first movie you're on top of the
train again and stuff like that um
honest like when we saw Shay wigam and
maybe it's because we see him in a lot
of roles similar to this I I had to be
like he wasn't already in this right
yeah to check myself for a minute I've
seen you pop up in enough of these kinds
of movies were you in a James Bond at
some point like it can get a little bit
confusing as to who was where who died
where who serves what role in which plot
um but yeah as far as the mission
Impossibles go I thought this was
another you know really enjoyable really
Punchy installment and I mean often
times I'll become kind of wary when
franchises start to wear long and have
especially like the same couple people
driving them and especially certain
franchises where it's like one director
for like nine installments and you're
like may we need some fresh blood but I
thought this was still yeah uh uh
energetic and Punchy and it had the
right amount of you know like world
rening heft but also it knew when to
have a little bit of fun and uh and I'm
intrigued you know by whatever's coming
in the next one yeah I think before I
could like comfortably settle this
anywhere in my list I I I feel like I
need to hold off for the second part so
I can feel it together I I I I still
think Fallout might be I think it's
still my favorite up until this point if
I had to solidify it I'm pretty
confident that right I'm standing with
that at least for right now I might meet
yeah I might I might meet you there I
mean mi3 is is a contender I mean Ghost
Protocol is is probably like one of the
most fun um but yeah Fallout might be
the Fallout might be the Pinnacle um but
at where I'm standing man it's still a
joy you know to be watching I don't any
of them like that's like I feel like for
a franchise that's what seven movies in
to be like hey that was kind of a
stinker we I don't feel like we have one
like you know you might point to Mission
Impossible 2 cuz it's very much the
black sheep of them all but like it's
still super fun to watch yeah even with
that 45 pages expanded with
slow-mo but uh hey you got you got any
stray thoughts before we wrap this up I
think we've spilled all the ink that
needs spilling no I'm I think I I think
I'm good all right well before we get
out of here I feel like we should if you
would indulge me engage in a patron of
the day shout out and you can help me
out here uh I'm going to write up a
quick little mad lib in Chad gbt as we
have been doing oh god um all right it's
going to be good it's going to be a good
one and who better to shout out today
than Gabriel so uh
so but you're giving it to the entity I
know well hey that's the thing man we're
all in there already man Gabriel's
probably done 20 lenses by now 50 words
describing him saving the world from an
apocalypse scenario give me your
favorite Mission Impossible actor
Michael ah Jeremy rener cuz he's not in
it anymore it still counts give me uh a
McGuffin uh I'm going with the Chimera
there we go came to mind how how about
an adjective we'll make it easy rogue
rogue perfect one word from one of the
subtitles
protocol protocol give me an animal Hawk
Hawk and give me a job a weird job tax
Driver Taxi Driver and give me a a word
that's like a normal word but that you
think is funny
uh juice juice all right here we go I'm
going to read our shared Masterpiece
right now amidst an apocalypse Rogue
Chimera Unleashed chaos Gabriel our
super sexy reject resembling Jeremy
rener activated a secret protocol armed
with hawk-like precision he teamed up
with a Fearless Taxi Driver together
they sipped juice plotted strategy and
thwarted the threat saving the world
hats off to
Gabriel 50 words really limited that
[Music]
story usually for these machine shout
outs 50 words has been a sweet spot but
this is like if you're if you're looking
for AI to replace the writers uh this
was not the best example of how that is
about to happen take notes Studios
anyway Gabriel we appreciate you being
here um I tried to work into the shout
out that that you're not the angel
Gabriel you're not religious but it
didn't include any of that because
machines I guess don't acknowledge you
know religion but anyway thanks for
being here bud and we'll catch you next
month thank you all for watching this
video and uh Mike thank you for joining
me I appreciate you anytime man yeah
hopefully again soon be well people
peace